while migrants continue to pour into the
United States critics of the president
maintain that nothing can be done
because of walls useless CNN's Brian
carome recently ranted about the
futility of mankind's oldest defensive
mechanism
this whole issue is a crock from start
to finish he picked it up on the
campaign trail of something to appease
the masses and play to his base it's not
gonna stop terrorism it's not gonna be
2,000 miles long as originally planned
it's not gonna be see-through
it's not gonna be eco-friendly it's not
gonna be slats or heads on pikes or a
beaded curtain or anything else
you can't wall that border jimmy kimmel
meanwhile has been ridiculing Americans
were so desperate for a secure border
they've been willing to donate to a
GoFundMe campaign for it
this Trump supporter guy named Brian
Cole Fahd started to GoFundMe campaign
to raise a billion dollars for the wall
he launched it on Sunday it's already up
to almost nine million dollars people
this is what people do with their
disposable income when they don't have
loans from college to pay off donating
money for a wall that will never exist
it's like starting a college fund for
Harry Potter it's a it's a wait a more
useful thing to do with your money would
be to go outside and feed it to a bird
but you do have to admire the sacrifice
they're making a lot of these people are
dipping into their meth money for this
got it meth heads for national security
Thank You Jimmy
so would a wall work or not Jason
piccolo is a former Special Agent and
supervisor with the Department of
Homeland Security and he joins us now
everybody's mocking this we've had Nancy
Pelosi doing her beaded curtain line at
this stage I would welcome a 2,000 mile
beaded curtain along the southern border
it would show a certain kind of resolve
but are these critics right that this
thing doesn't work doesn't make any
difference complete waste of time now
it'll work now the border is 2,000 miles
long and you won't be able to actually
wall the whole border but that'll create
choke points or points where we could
actually apprehend the immigrants coming
in yes what would work yeah what's
interesting to me is that if you look at
up on the northern border
there's far fewer people coming across
there's not caravans massing on the 49th
parallel and yet the United States
government has actually put physical
barricades in a lot of cross border
towns on the Canadian border presumably
because it works there so why would it
not work on the Mexican border what work
they do now when I worked on a border
you the border was simply a strand of
fence in some areas like a strand of
wire now you have narco traffickers
coming across that same area you have
economic migrants it's just it's open
the whole border is pretty much open
except for you know a few miles here and
there when when you say it's open
because most most people who cross
international frontiers legitimately
will do so a big border posts but you're
saying that even though we talk about
this incessantly there are actually
hundred mile stretches where people can
actually just walk into the United
States a country that supposedly been on
orange alert for 17 years yeah
definitely
now I was on the DHS as a human
smuggling cell back in 2015 and we
tracked human smuggling corridors coming
up from South America now you do have
special interest aliens transiting into
South America into Brazil and traveling
up those same routes that the economic
migrants and a narco traffickers are
using so there anybody can come and go
through that border so you mean you mean
when you say special interest aliens you
mean that potential jihadists have
figured out they look at what's on their
TV screens on the Rio Grande and figure
that instead of trying to fly to JFK you
might as well just go to Latin America
and walk into the country you can the
border is open now I detailed out in Ajo
Arizona at one time back in the early
2000s and it was literally one strand of
barbed wire so yes you could anybody
could walk across that border when the
ferries intent are with coming here for
economic migration a strand of barbed
wire that seems even more useless than
the beaded card and Jason thank you for
that and thank you for the
eyewitness testimony on that southern
board I'm not sure people actually
visualize it quite the way you know it